одним зі спиць сумки в річковому побачить і
українського прем'єра стало з проб
буквальному sensi виносить і євою громадою
заряду the hot shops трибуни причому у
ініціатива виходу ловити депутата вигляд
блоку петра порошенка
по призову країні у пристрасті стінах
верховної ради за сідні експерти
називають перетинання тарифу на енергетику
ніхто не дефолту та закрити а проблеми
банки в економічному та успіхом про
яценюка
проте shemale її проблему gabbana
інтерв'ю вона була проведена 1 злісних
реформ реформа у редуту деш служби
зарплати чиновники в Україні якіра ніші
до смішного миски з ми пропустимо ще в
україні дешту школи титри мій зарплату
на яку на реально прожитий ось наші
адже експерти за стріляють нових
політичних потрясінь столітті може за
галімова the heat українських реформ я
думаю головне харчування у того як можна
зборах ти про реформатор нудьгу алісію з
новим прем'єром
топ то як створи ти нову частину
верховній раді і поки ціп це не я не
буду ви вирішено мені здається і його рота
мене ти прем'єри просто і не варто
міняти приклад ті ось і дні і в брюсселі
піджак на засіданні раді асоціації
україна-єс
та друк приїзду віце-президента Байдена
до києва звучала критика через
правильність уряду яценюка
помруть без корупцію, проте ви міг
правити ставка вид захисних партнерів не
прозвучало за раз абсолютно нато
дільничний потрібен мене-то українського
прем'єр-міністра порядку і вам на
небагато викладки vcr і формою і вина на
сході і курс спочила Росії проти
україни там удару спаллетті зайві 3 в
середини української влади
може стати кухонним сигналом для заходу
голова комітету європарламенту та
закордонних праворуч ельмар брок на
ворожий вигляд тієї далекої за реформи на
сцені кілька прем'єр і президент США
харчування уряду панель ціную до шляхом на жаль
катування в сівалки влади вся система павича
проти ти над реформами та всі партію
коаліції і президент всі ви не
просила ти розум на результат і на сам
процес робота над мінськими
домовленостями про тантризм нам і дав
конституції будь-який привід
сам арсеній яценюк вже обізнаний
описані популярні crocker його рейтинг
впав теж давши відразу мід ще готовий
Давид ставкою Yaxell витрачати петренко
верховної ради